[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
im Alter von 17 Jahren wird Lisa mcway
von einem unbekannten Mann vom Fahrrad
gestoßen entführt in sein Haus gebracht
und 26 Stunden lang vergewaltigt der
Zeitpunkt ist gerade zu absurd denn Lisa
wollte sich in dieser Nacht eigentlich
das Leben nehmen in Ihrem Zuhause bei
ihrer Großmutter wird sie seit Jahren
ohne jeden Skrupel und ohne Hemmungen
missbraucht und zwar vom Freund ihrer
Großmutter die sogar davon weiß und ist
billigt damit herzlich willkommen zum
zweiten Teil dieser schrecklichen
Geschichte ich bin Toni Haier und ich
bin Mirko Kasimir hallo
jetzt wo Lisa in der Hand eines
Entführers und Vergewaltigers ist sind
alle Selbstmordgedanken verflogen Lisa
macht sich zwar keine Illusionen über
eine Flucht aus der Gewalt des Mannes
aber sie merkt sich jedes Detail Farben
Namen Orte Treppen und sie erfindet
einen kranken Vater und erzählt ihrem
Peiniger dass dieser auf Ihre Hilfe
angewiesen sei und dass sie sich Sorgen
um ihn mache was solle nur aus ihm
werden wenn sie tot ist nur wegen ihm
bettelt sie um ihr Leben in einem
Interview mit dem Fernsehsender TV
erzählt Lisa später irgendwann nimmt er
meine Hand und legt sie auf sein Gesicht
der Idiot jetzt weiß ich wie er aussieht
und ich kann fühlen dass er einen
kleinen Schnurrbart hat einige Pocken
Narben auf der Haut eine Stupsnase er
ist nicht dick er fühlt sich sehr sauber
an
als er mich auf die Toilette gehen lässt
hinterlasse ich überall meine
Fingerabdrücke falls er mich umbringt
soll die Polizei wissen dass ich darf
war doch er bringt sie nicht um in den
frühen Morgenstunden des nächsten Tages
gibt er ihr ein Hemd das offensichtlich
von einer anderen Frau stammt und sagt
ihr sie solle sich anziehen ich bringe
dich nach Hause sagte er und Lisa kann
es nicht glauben sie ist sich sicher
dass er mit ihr an einen einsamen Ort
fahren und sie töten wird
sie steigen wieder in sein Auto nach
einer kurzen Fahrt hält er an einem
Geldautomaten später an einer Tankstelle
wenn du versuchst zu schreien werde ich
den Tank war töten sagte er dann komme
ich zurück und töte dich
Lisa schreit nicht kurz darauf fahren
Sie weiter dann halten sie erneut und
der Entführer der entschuldigt sich bei
ihr und er lässt sie frei er sagt erzähl
deinem Vater dass er der Grund ist warum
ich dich nicht umgebracht habe
das ist so heftig diese erfundene
Geschichte von einem kranken Vater hat
dieses Herz von dem ekelhaften Typen
erweicht das Herz dieses Mannes der
einer Jungfrau all diese schrecklichen
furchtbaren Dinge antun konnte ohne
irgendwelche Gewissens besser und der
sie ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken
getötet hätte wie sehr kann man Frauen
hassen tja für ihn war das
wahrscheinlich so dass er in Frauen
nicht mal mehr menschliche Wesen gesehen
hat während er mit dem imaginären Vater
von Lisa irgendeiner Art Verbundenheit
gespürt hat
ja vollkommen verdreht ihr sagt ihr sie
solle aussteigen und fünf Minuten warten
dann könne sie die Augenbinde abnehmen
und nach Hause gehen
und dann fährt er los
lisa ist erstaunt und verwirrt und alles
andere als erleichtert fünf Minuten wird
er es sich gleich anders überlegen ist
das ganze nur ein Trick kommt er gleich
zurück um sie zu überfahren und alles
wie ein Autounfall aussehen zu lassen
sie wartet keine fünf Minuten sie reißt
sich die Augenbinde vom Kopf und sieht
eine alte Eiche die ihr vorkommt wie das
schönste dass sie je in ihrem Leben
gesehen hat
danach rennt sie los
[Musik]
klingt nach einer guten Schlussszene
oder aber das ist noch nicht das Happy
End dass wir euch versprochen haben denn
der Ort zu dem Lisa rennt ist kein
Zuhause sondern der Schauplatz anderer
Verbrechen die über Jahre an ihr verübt
wurden gegen 4 Uhr 30 kommt sie am Haus
ihrer Großmutter an und hämmert gegen
die Tür der Freund ihrer Großmutter
öffnet die Tür packt sie an den Haaren
zerrt sie ins Haus und schleudert sie zu
Boden und dann setzt er dem ganzen
Schrecken noch eins oben drauf
er verhört Sie mehrere Stunden lang und
wirft ihr vor ihn betrogen zu haben das
ist so eine kranke Unterstellung also
was für ein Hund wenn man bedenkt was
Lisa gerade durchmacht und vor allem
auch dieses betrogen entschuldigung das
ist der Mann ihrer Oma sie ist ein
teenage girl er hat überhaupt gar nichts
mit ihr zu tun oder auch gar kein Recht
auf sie sie gehört nur sich selbst und
das ganz krank was er da macht
vollkommen richtig
die Großmutter ruft schließlich die
Polizei an und das natürlich nicht um
ihre Enkelin zu helfen die Polizei sucht
nach der vermissten 17-Jährigen aber
warte sie haben sie als vermisst
gemeldet naja zum einen wurden natürlich
das Fahrrad und vermutlich auch noch
andere persönliche Gegenstände am Ort
der Entführung gefunden und dann wollte
ihr perverser Freund sie vielleicht
einfach zurück haben um sie weiter zu
missbrauchen
die Großmutter behauptet dass Mädchen
sei nur ausgerissen und habe sich eine
Entführungsgeschichte ausgedacht um sich
wichtig zu machen
doch da bereits eine offizielle
Untersuchung angelaufen ist bestehen die
Beamten darauf dass Lisa auf das Revier
kommt und die ganze Sache abgeschlossen
werden kann auf der Wache erzählt Lisa
ihre ganze Geschichte nein nicht die
ganze nur die Geschichte ihrer
Entführung
vom Missbrauch durch den Freund ihrer
Großmutter sagt sie nichts
Lisa sitzt eine Polizistin gegenüber das
klingt erstmal gut aber die Polizistin
glaubt ihr nicht
Lisa erscheint ihr zur ruhig und diese
ganzen Details die sie sich angeblich
gemerkt haben will und diese Geschichte
mit dem Tampon im Auto und den
Fingerabdrücken die sie im Bad
hinterlassen hat also welches
entführungs- und Vergewaltigungsopfer
hätte unter Todesangst so eine
Geistesgegenwart die Polizistin lässt
sich die Geschichte immer wieder
erzählen und irgendwann fährt Lisa sie
an nein nicht noch einmal bringen sie
mir jemanden intelligenteres
[Musik]
am nächsten Tag spricht Lisa mit
Sergeant Larry pinkerten und der glaubt
ihr endlich die Suche nach ihrem
Entführer beginnt und sie wird
schreckliches zutage fördern ein paar
Tage später sitzt Lisa zuhause als im
Fernsehen über ein Verbrechen in der
Gegend berichtet wird eine weitere
Leiche sei aufgetaucht Nummer 8 in einer
grausamen Serie von Frauenmorden und
irgendetwas an dieser Nachricht lässt
Lisa aufhorchen ihre Nackenhaare stellen
sich auf so sagt sie ihr später im
Interview sie ruft Larry pinkerten an
und sagt ihm dass sie glaube dass der
Mörder derselbe Mann sei der sie
entführt habe
und dass sie helfen könne
pinkerten glaubt ihr auch diesmal sie
beschließen Lisa zu hypnotisieren um
auch noch die letzten Details von ihr zu
erfahren aber
Lisa ist erst 17 sie brauchen die
Einwilligung der Erziehungsberechtigten
und der Freund der Großmutter ist nicht
bereit sie zu erteilen endlich bricht es
aus Lisa hervor sie erzählt pink hatten
was er in diesem Haus von diesem Mann
seit Jahren angetan wurde und endlich
endlich wird dieser Typ verhaftet und
Lisa von diesem horrorort weggebracht
vorerst in ein Heim für entlaufene
Jugendliche in den folgenden Befragungen
und Hypnose-Sitzungen kommen weitere
Details ans Licht vor allem eins lässt
die Ermittler aufrauchen der rote
Teppich den Lisa gleich zu Anfang auf
dem Boden des Wagens gesehen hat an
allen Mordopfern wurden Faserspuren
eines roten Teppichs gefunden ein
weiteres extrem wichtiges Detail der
Schriftzug Magnum den Lisa auf dem
armaturenbretterkantert und dass sie
wusste dass es ein rotes Auto war jetzt
wissen die Ermittler dass sie einen
roten Dodge Magnum suchen und stellen
eine Liste von Besitzern eines solchen
Wagens in der Gegend zusammen und ihr
erinnert euch bevor der Täter Lisa frei
ließ hielt er an einem Geldautomaten die
Beamten erstellen mit Hilfe der Banken
eine zweite Liste mit den Namen von
Kontoinhabern die in der fraglichen
nachtgeld abgehoben haben
Einnahme taucht auf beiden Listen auf
Barbie Joe long 31 Jahre alt der
Frauenmörder von Tampa Bay ist gefunden
dank der 17-jährigen Lisa mcway 10 Morde
gehen auf longs Konto zehn Frauen
vergewaltigt getötet
zehn Leben genommen und wer weiß wie
viele Leben zerstört
und wer weiß wie viele dieses Schicksal
noch geteilt hätten wenn nicht eine
junge Frau so geistesgegenwärtig und vor
allem mutig gewesen wäre Bobby Joe long
wird zum Tode verurteilt als er 2019
nach 35 Jahren in der Todeszelle mit der
tödlichen Injektion hingerichtet wird
sitzt Lisa mcway im Zuschauerraum in der
ersten Reihe ich kann mir vorstellen
also ich bin kein Fan der Todesstrafe
ich bin absolut dagegen aber ich kann
mir vorstellen dass es für Lisa
vielleicht so eine Art fast
heilen kann man nicht sagen aber das ist
irgendwie ein Abschluss war und
vielleicht musste sie auch mit eigenen
Augen sehen um zu glauben dass dieser
Mann wirklich tot ist dass dieses Trauma
endlich zu Ende ist ja aber egal wie mit
dem Trauma zu leben ist ist furchtbar
aber auch eine Menschen beim Sterben
zuzusehen das stelle ich mir auch nicht
leicht vor mit Sicherheit nicht
sicherlich keine schöne Vorstellung
aber jetzt können wir endlich den guten
Teil der Geschichte von Lisa mcway
erzählen denn nach diesen ganzen
Vorkommnissen nahmen Lisa ihr Leben
endlich in ihrer eigenen Hände sie und
Zargen pinkerten wurden beste Freunde
und Lisa wurde Polizistin im Interview
mit Amy TV 2021 sagt sie im Jahr 2004
absolvierte ich die Polizeiakademie ich
habe sie selbst bezahlt seit 17 Jahren
arbeite ich im Hillsboro County Sheriff
Office und seit sieben Jahren als
Verbindungsfrau der Polizei an Schulen
alle wissen dass ich Mama Bär bin
niemand legt sich mit meinen Kindern an
und meine Kinder wissen das sie erzählte
den Schulkindern lange nichts von ihren
eigenen Erlebnissen bis eines Tages ein
Junge ihr sagte
wir haben gestern Abend ein paar Videos
gesehen und du hast geholfen einen
Bösewicht zu fangen tut mir leid dass
das passiert ist der Beauty aber du bist
ein Held
seither spricht sie auch in den Schulen
darüber und wenn ein Schüler
niedergeschlagen ist erzähle ich ihm
eine Geschichte über ein Mädchen das von
seiner Familie verlassen
entführt und vergewaltigt wurde und ich
sage glaubst du sie hat ihren Weg
verloren nein sie ist Polizistin
gerade an
und damit sind wir am Ende dieser
unglaublich schrecklichen und auch
irgendwie auch Hoffnung machen den
Geschichte der Entführung von Lisa mcway
wichtige Quellen für unsere Episode
waren unter anderem das Interview mit
Lisa mcway auf anetv Folge 22 des
amerikanischen Podcasts not today und
diverse zeitungs- und Internetartikel
zum Thema und an dieser Stelle auch noch
schaut out an unsere Kolleginnen des
True Crime Podcasts Mord auf X die haben
eine wirklich ganz ganz tolle Folge zu
Lisa produziert und dafür auch mit ihr
selbst gesprochen die Episode heißt wie
man einen Serienmörder überlebt er
findet sie überall auf allen gängigen
Plattformen also wenn ihr da Lust habt
noch mehr zu erfahren und auch von
dieser selbst dann hört da mal rein wir
hoffen ihr fandet dieses Story genauso
spannend und aufwühlend wie wir und hört
auch gern beim nächsten Mal wieder rein
deshalb danke fürs zuhören und bis zum
nächsten Mal
euer Mirko und eure tun